last name first name warren jasmine guys  she got their room  legends  lancaster college is crowded with them  when you go to a school that's nearly as  old as the country you can expect to  hear a few  it can be really hard for students of  color just know i'm here  it's amazing kel  first black master very exciting it is  [Music]  [Music]  so you live here too  yeah  the whole school's cursed okay you're to  have to try a lot harder than that  seriously it's it's real  i understand  i went through it  can i just  this school is unwilling to see itself  for what it truly is  [Music]  i've been having nightmares  you look like you seen a ghost  [Music]  why is this administration spending more  energy undermining my tenure  than unferreting alpha's been  terrorizing the student body  you can't get away from that jasmine  it'll follow you  [Music]  it's everywhere  [Music]  you